quatre axes prioritaires dans la lutte
contre la fraude tout d'abord les
stupéfiants 0,8 tonnes de produits ont
été saisis en 2017 pour les cigarettes
et le tabac de contrebande cela
représente 300 kg on note également une
forte augmentation des produits de
contrefaçon plus de 3400 articles saisis
concernant les capitaux illicites 650000
euros non déclarée ont fait l'objet
d'une dénonciation
un constat concernant les stupéfiants la
tendance est inversée cette année il ya
plus de saisies de cannabis de cocaïne
460 kilos de cannabis saisis cette année
contre 375 kg de cocaïne
autre constat le nombre de trafics sous
le fret express et le fret postal a
doublé depuis 2013 et constituent une
part de plus en plus importante des
contentieux réalisé par les services des
douanes en martinique